and we do of course want to warn you the
video may be disturbing to see or hear
this all happened back in may when
henderson police were getting calls
about a suspicious man who was walking
through a neighborhood officers
responding to that neighborhood near
lake mead parkway and boulder highway
after a neighbor called police about a
man possibly on drugs breaking into cars
officers chasing that suspect into a
backyard the 23 year old did not listen
to commands and then ended up hiding
behind a wall
moments before the shooting the man
brought his hand above that wall
in in it is what police thought was a
gun you can see that now in this video
if you reach for a gun you're going to
get shot do you understand stand up let
me see your finger
you're good you're good you're good
you're good
in their presentation today henderson
police did not update the suspect's
condition only saying he was treated
the gun by the way was a bb gun it is
just one question eight news now would
have asked but the information today was
released on video no news conference no
reporters no opportunity to provide any
neighbors complete reporting of this
officer-involved shooting i'm david
charns live local now